if the left did not have double
standards they would have no standards
at all we're seeing this play out now
especially as the media
are convinced that we're moving into a
democratic administration
you're seeing a huge shift in the way
that the media are covering politicians
the way the politicians are reacting to
the people even
some prominent left-wingers are
admitting this fact sarah silverman
criticize her all you want but at least
she was honest recently
on a podcast she was describing why it
seems like the left plays by a totally
different set of rules and she admitted
it's because
liberals get to do whatever they want
so what do you think is the difference
between you saying it and somebody else
sing it and not getting away with it it
seems like you get away with a lot of
stuff
because you're so funny but it's some of
it's pretty dark
i think it's the intention behind it
like
yeah this is a math term but it's kind
of like the absolute power of the joke
like especially back then i always said
the opposite of
what i thought you know and that was the
joke kinda and then
hopefully the truth transcends that i
don't really
feel this way not to break it down in
the least funny
possible way but it is also interesting
too because like
that comedy i did you're right it
it was like oh it's okay because you
know i don't mean it
but then it also is kind of like we're
liberal
so we can say anything so we could say
you know the words that are unsayable or
whatever like
you know i don't mean it so i could say
it like there is kind of like a liberal
like
douchiness about it i think in in
retrospect i mean i don't know it's a
weird balance
you know not the phrase i would have
come up with but probably totally
precise
that's what we're seeing play out right
now this is this is a shifting
of standards that is only going to
get worse and worse and worse over the
next weeks and probably
the next years and hopefully we can
still push back against it i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show speaking of
shifting standards we
yesterday were talking about that gal
who who played on the vanderbilt
football team for
like five minutes and then they lost 41
to nothing and i don't maybe those were
unrelated events
my favorite comment from yesterday from
christopher rodriguez who says
with the way vanderbilt plays i thought
they always had women on the team
that's that's not nice that's playing on
old standards
and stereotypes and it's not politically
correct
to say that the left
is replacing old standards with
new standards double standards for
themselves they're replacing the
conventional standards with
political correctness this is a point we
were discussing quite a lot yesterday
because i i think that the right totally
misunderstands this moment they
misunderstand
how to combat these new standards of
political correctness that the left is
forcing on them i'll give you a perfect
example of this
came out yesterday from steve schmidt
steve schmidt is
he says he's a republican he's not
really a republican he's a liberal
republican
he ran a lot of squishy republican
campaigns and lost
and his job basically as a consultant
was to enrich himself
by losing republican races and then
saying really nice things about
democrats
he's a court jester conservative you
might call him
uh as the the phrase that i've been
using the past few weeks
and as we've been seeing around us a
whole lot so
yesterday steve schmidt decides he's
he's
got the strange new respective liberals
all the liberals are very nice to him he
is
functionally a liberal he tweets out one
of the most vile
rants against ann coulter that i've ever
read
and people have very strong feelings
about ann coulter i really like ann
coulter but some people they hate her
and she's terrible and she's this and
she's that
this is what steve schmidt had to say
about her
to her on on twitter you are a cancer
you are a vile and disgusting human
being who has made herself a
multi-millionaire praying on the weak
and the stupid
you're a racist and a fascist fdr said
judge me by my enemies i'm delighted to
be yours trump will lose he'll be
disgraced and one day somewhere
someone hopefully many years from now
who was born after these days end
will read your obituary and understand
what an open and fetid
sore you were on our politics it will be
a small paragraph for an unaccomplished
and not long remembered lonely person
who sowed hate vitriol and division you
are pathetic
you can see steve schmidt's very upset
about hate vitriol and division
what did ann do to deserve this kind of
reaction
she tweeted at an article that
criticized steve schmidt's career
not this personal kind of thing and this
is what he says
imagine speaking to a woman this way any
woman
your worst enemy woman you totally hate
imagine if you were a real man
not like steve schmidt but an actual man
speaking to a woman this way
absolutely disgusting so i made this
point i said this is not the way
that men should speak to women and
what i heard first of all obviously if
it had been flipped if it had been
a conservative man talking about a
liberal woman this way the guy would
probably be at rikers right now he'd
probably be in alcatraz
ostracized from the country perhaps but
because it's a liberal man saying this
about a conservative woman he's allowed
to get away with it but no man should be
able to say this about any woman so i
point this out and the left responds to
me and they say a lot of
liberal women they say oh he's not
saying about a woman he's saying about
ann coulter
oh yeah it doesn't matter aunt coulter
gets whatever whatever she deserves
steve schmidt responded to me he said oh
yeah i'm glad that i said that about
ann coulter very womanish response not
womanly
that's when women behave like women but
woman-ish it's when men behave
with the worst characteristics and
stereotypes of women
and one response i got broadly from the
left was they said
michael i thought you guys hate identity
politics
who cares if a man says it to a woman or
a woman says it to a man or a man says
it to a man or a woman says it to a
woman it doesn't matter there's no
difference
yes there is yes there is
men should behave differently in front
of women than they would
in front of other men there is greater
latitude for the way that men behave at
the bar with their with the men and the
sailors
than there is for the way that men
behave in front of women
any woman don't care if you don't like
her that's
that's an old standard it's not identity
politics that's called chivalry
edmund burke the very conservative
philosopher said
in reflections on the revolution in
france he lamented he said the age of
chivalry is gone
that of sofasters economists and
calculators has succeeded
and the glory of europe is extinguished
forever chivalry is the standard
identity politics is the new politically
correct left-wing standard
that the left is trying to replace
chivalry with and a bunch of even
sort of moderates or conservatives will
come out and say ah well
we should have no standards at all we we
don't want identity politics but
if we don't own identity politics we
can't have chivalry either if we don't
want the new politically correct
standard we can't have the old standards
either
that's bs that's ridiculous we we need
to have those old standards if we don't
have those old standards
if we don't have some standard at all
some understanding of virtue and
behavior
and the way we ought to relate to
society then we
we have no political vision that's
political visions require
politics just means how we all get along
together but political vision requires
that you
understand and have some sense of how we
all get along together
and it's this misunderstanding is part
of the big reason
that that oscar-nominated actresses
are becoming or pretending to be men now
and men
are behaving this way in front of women
and we're all so vicious to one another
regardless of our sex and even
regardless
of our of our positions in society
because we we no longer have a standard
and when that happens you have social
collapse it's really difficult you know
you see this
in certain areas of the country where
where
maybe jobs have been shipped overseas
and standards have collapsed
you're in you're in pretty bad straights
and actually a guy who was raised in one
of these situations raised in a trailer
park with no clear path to success
kicked out of high school multiple times
and faced with becoming a father in his
teens is
jason waller the definition of a true
underdog after hearing the words no
or you can't too many times jason
unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies
his most recent venture rather is
power home solar skyrocketing on a path
to becoming a billion dollar enterprise
join us as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year winner shares
motivational tips and inspiring stories
along with business building lessons
from the ground up
he shares his life experiences to help
others better themselves and as waller
will tell you
there is no elevator to success that
climb only happens one
step at a time let every true underdog
podcast be that step that elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure learn about
entrepreneurship
learn about never quitting or making
excuses it is real
it is raw it is motivational there are a
lot of people in our
politics these days who are trying to
discourage you don't want you to keep
fighting
on you should fight on check out true
underdog podcast at trueunderdog.com
or anywhere you get your podcasts
total total double standard the new the
new standards
are the problem but the fact that we
don't have old standards anymore we
don't have any whatsoever as
conservatives
is a big problem too i give you an
example of this kind of
the dishonesty of political correctness
of woke-ism of whatever term you want to
use
nike nike might be the single
wokest company on the face of the earth
colin kaepernick
back in years and years ago when he was
still playing football
decides to protest the american flag the
symbol of the country
what does nike do well-known american
company
that ships job overseas and uses
overseas labor and cheap labor and slave
labor
nike hires him to be their spokesman
taking a stand against the american flag
nike was going to produce a shoe with
the revolutionary war flag on the back
the betsy ross flag
colin kaepernick said no you can't do
that the american revolution is bad you
can't
you can't have that sure so nike as woke
as they get specifically in
this alleged issue of civil rights
because that's how
colin kaepernick is is pretending that
he is uh
supporting nike
has apparently been lobbying against a
bill that would ban
imports of products made from china
using
slave uighur labor they were
well that's so weird i thought nike was
for civil rights
but we know that china where they're
getting a lot of their cheap cheap
products we know that china uses slave
labor we know that they're
they're putting a whole population the
uyghurs into
labor camps so surely nike wouldn't want
to use that slave labor right wrong they
actually lobbied against it not just
nike coca-cola
apple also sought to weaken legislation
that would bar u.s companies from
relying on the forced labor of uyghurs
and other muslim muslim minorities in
particular in china's
xinjiang region that is according to
business in insider
well of course because they they want to
pretend
that they're woke right they want to
foist this kind of
woke politically correct standard on you
but they don't want to follow it
themselves and nike isn't really the
problem here the problem is not
the the deeply held political beliefs of
nike and coca-cola and apple
the problem is the cowardice of nike
coca-cola and apple
because they will acquiesce to the most
fanciful
activism of their locust employees and
they will acquiesce
to the the often most anti-american
elements in public activism in the
country
they have no standards and so they just
go along and follow the almighty dollar
i'm all for making a buck
but you have to do that within a moral
framework and these guys are not doing
that at all
now the question is when we point out
this double standard this hypocrisy
is nike going to pay for it no
no they're not i a lot of times
conservatives want to point out and say
haha
the liberals say they believe in this
but then they violate that
the perfect example of course is the
liberals say that they're
tolerant but actually they're behaving
in an intolerant way
so much for the tolerant left right this
is a line that's become a cliche
and the the reason that it it has no
effect is that the left
doesn't care the left knows that they're
intolerant
in fact the father of the new left
herbert
wrote an essay in the 1960s called
repressive tolerance where he explicitly
says we should not tolerate
conservatives we should not tolerate
right-wing ideas we should tolerate our
ideas
and actually the guy's got a point you
can't
you you can't tolerate everything
this is a finite world we've got to have
boundaries on it so for instance you
can't tolerate
intolerance chesterton made this point
he said there's a thought that stops
thought and that's the only thought that
ought to be stopped
there is speech that stops speech like
the heckler's veto and so you can't so
or sedition actually for that matter it
undercuts the first amendment
so obviously there are constraints here
the left does not care about appearing
hypocritical according to other
standards what they're trying to do
is replace those standards with new ones
the left doesn't care about the uyghurs
in china and we can
we can yell about the uyghurs until
we're blue in the face it won't matter
the left doesn't care about freedom
doesn't care about slavery
the the point of the new standards that
they are foisting on us from the 1619
project
all the way up to gender ideology which
we'll get to in just a second with this
actress in hollywood
the point of it is purely negative
it is to overturn the
established order the 1619 project is a
great example
the 1619 project has as its central
thesis
that the point of the american
revolution was to preserve slavery
that that is the thesis of the whole
thing and the new york times puts it out
and spends millions of dollars promoting
this and it goes into classrooms
academic historians most of whom are
left-wing come out and say
actually guys that's not true
there's no evidence of that there's a
lot of evidence to the contrary the new
york times finally after months and
months
has to make a correction it says okay
actually yeah no that wasn't
the reason for the american revolution
but they leave the article
they keep putting money into the 1619
project
because the point of the 1619 project is
not to follow a thesis about how slavery
caused the american revolution
the protection of slavery rather the
point of the 6019 project is to get you
to hate your country
the you see this with the sexual
revolution that the left constantly
exploiting
groups of people who have sort of
unusual sexual desires
you see this notably with the homosexual
movement and the transsexual movement
homosexual movement says there are two
sexes men
and women and you are born with your
innate sexual desires it's not just a
preference that can change it is a
sexual orientation you are born this way
nobody would choose this right these are
all the things we've heard from that
wing
of the sexual revolution for decades now
and therefore we need to accept people's
varying sexual uh desires okay
fair enough argument right but then you
get the transsexual or transgender
argument and they say
there is no such thing as biological sex
uh there are more sexes
also there are more gender expressions
gender is different than sex how exactly
we can't quite tell
men can become women women can become
men and there's nothing
innate or immutable about it but of
course if that were the case
first of all if transgenderism is true
then there actually have to be real
categories
of men and women because it's the only
way to explain how men could become
women
also there's this contradiction within
transgenderism which is that on the one
hand
sex is so essential to our sense of
selves that if
if you are if you look like a man but
you feel like a woman then you'll have
to go through very expensive mutilations
and
totally try to transform your body to
more closely appear like the sex that
you identify as
but also there's no such thing as real
sex and a man really can become a woman
and a woman can become a man
or anything in the middle well those
things don't
compute they don't add up the left
doesn't care the point of
all of these ideas all of which are
internally inconsistent with the broader
left-wing program
the point of it is just to smash the old
standards
so it doesn't matter one day the kind of
born this way argument works okay good
okay we'll do born this way
one day gender is a social construct
works okay well you use gender as a
social construct
it doesn't matter that they don't go
along together when you recognize that
the
only thing they're after the only thing
the left is after is this kind of
revolution
that is whitaker chambers writes in in
witness whitaker chambers
a famous ex-communist he's the basically
the guy who turned reagan into a
conservative through his book
he says the difference between
freedom and communism it's not that
they're new ideologies
communism is the second oldest ideology
in the world that goes back to
the garden of eden when the serpent told
eve ye should be his gods
you shall be as gods you can do whatever
you want
you can be whatever you want and of
course that's not the case because we're
in
a finite world and this brings us to our
friend
ellen page i can't say that i'm going to
this podcast is going to be taken down
if i use the phrase ellen page
i will admit something i have no idea
who ellen page is
i wouldn't recognize her i couldn't pick
her out of a lineup i don't think i've
seen her movies
somebody told me she was in inception
and i did see that movie but i don't
remember her
i don't i haven't seen her stuff but
apparently she's a famous actress
and she was a lesbian
apparently by the way there is a
connection to ellen page
during 2015 during the run up to the
2016 election
ellen page this very left-wing then
lesbian actress
walked up to ted cruz who also didn't
recognize her and
starts picking a debate with him about
lgbt rights
and sexuality and take a list it wasn't
particularly coherent it's very funny
you can tell she's frustrated that cruz
doesn't know who she is
this was her perspective in
for just strictly 2015 gay or trans well
what we're seeing right now
is actually we're seeing
bible-believing christians being
persecuted so for example one of the
couples
no for living according to their faith
so for example
all right and segregation era i'm happy
to answer your question but not to have
a back and forth debate
if they were murdering people it would
be wrong
but in iran and isis it is the
governmental body that is executing them
for being homosexual
and why does the obama administration
not stand against us i don't know i
would love to talk to obama about it
that'd be great well good then we're
agreed on that no well
we're not don't do that and eventually
she just sort of
walks away says listen lady you know
i've answered your questions and she
she goes away and she's obviously
dejected that he he doesn't know who she
is
she's no longer a lesbian so ellen page
is now identifying as elliott page which
means
according to gender ideology she has
been a man
the whole time nobody knew it she didn't
even know it but she has been a man
because she is her true self
according to this gnostic dualistic
ideology of transgenderism
whereby your body has nothing to do with
your true self your true self is
this purely metaphysical entity she was
always a man which means
because she's she was identifying as a
lesbian she likes chicks it means
that for all these years a straight
white man
has been stealing the roles of women
and lesbians that's outrageous
that's a scandal and how you know the
patriarchy
strikes again she is a straight white
male she is therefore
uh part of the problem uh
she's not a man right she's obviously
not a man she's a woman she's
actually petite woman as you can see in
that video she's not particularly
masculine
now what is the issue here if she is a
straight white man
is she going to be castigated in the way
that straight white men are by this
left-wing culture
now there are there are actually quotas
you're not eligible for certain awards
in hollywood if you
have too many stray white men in the
in the movie so is she a straight white
man that's what she's saying she is
but not really because everyone knows
that she's a woman
and she's just identifying as a man and
she can do whatever she wants
she can do whatever she wants and it
just doesn't matter people are not going
to consider
ellen page on the same sexual
uh category as ted cruz for instance or
or as me they can do whatever they want
and i think
look we need to point out this hypocrisy
it's a big portion of this show is
identifying that
but we have to go further than that as
conservatives we need to recognize that
they don't care
if we call them hypocrites some of them
recognize the hypocrisy
most of them don't even acknowledge the
existence of objective truth
or or an objective moral standard right
one of the
points of this idea that gender is
socially constructed
one of the points of this idea that
intersectionality means that only my
suffering
is the the way that i can measure uh
moral goodness in the world
one of the points of progressivism
explicitly is that there are no fixed
laws to the universe
the the early progressives write about
this in almost these exact words
there are no fixed laws there is no
eternally true human nature
or sexuality or whatever that everything
is evolving and changing and so they
can't
they can't be held to account for those
standards because the standard they're
fosting on us is whatever they think
whatever the party says
is right we covered on my book show at
prageru 1984
where history is always being rewritten
standards are always being rewritten
language is always being rewritten and
whatever the party says is right
now that's become cliche to invoke
but there's a reason that george orwell
saw that happening
because that that is what's happening
right now and
the the way to fight that is not just to
point out the hypocrisy the way to fight
that
is to offer our own vision of things the
left is giving people
their vision the conservatives are not
giving people
our vision because we're too afraid to
make claims about
how we should live in the world how
families should be recognized how
small local governments should be made
up the relationship between the local
to the national how we ought to behave
because we've thrown our hands up in the
air and said you do you if it doesn't
scare the horses if it doesn't hurt
anybody else that's fine
no the reason that the left is winning
on the culture
is because people don't want that people
don't want to throw their hands up in
the air
people want a vision and conservatives
have failed to do that we need to fight
actually speaking of ted cruz ted cruz
one of the last elected republicans
who is actually sticking by the fight
and letting the legal process play out
on the 2020 election which we'll get to
in just one second
but i've got a more pressing problem
which is that sweet little alisa
deserves a very nice christmas present
and i'm very bad at picking out
christmas presents
i often go for jewelry but i don't
really i don't know that much about
jewelry and very often the good jewelry
is too expensive to afford one of the
most popular gifts you can possibly get
for the holidays very good reason for
that
and especially if you stick with the
classics fortunately i've got
the answer to these high jewelry prices
at the pearl source
where you get the highest quality pearl
jewelry at up to 70
off retail prices 70 percent off retail
why
because the pearl source cuts out the
middle man by eliminating traditional
5x markups by jewelry stores sells
directly to you the customer
if you've ever gone shopping for jewelry
in a store you know this is one of the
highest marked up
and and most opaque industries
you got to go to the pro source there's
no problem over here even if you need
the
the jewelry quickly perlsource offers
fast and free two-day shipping on every
order with zero contact delivery
pearlsource comes with a no hassle
60-day money-back guarantee so it's
totally risk-free
and with more than 20 years in the pearl
business and nearly 10 000 five-star
reviews
you can make sure you're shopping from a
trusted retailer do not overpay for
jewelry
go to the perl source save up to 70 off
of retail prices
for a limited time listeners to my show
can take 20
off your entire order for the holidays
go to the pearlsource.com
knowles enter promo code knowles at
checkout for 20 off your entire order
if you want fine pearl jewelry at the
best prices online go straight to the
source the pearlsource.com
knowles and enter promo code knowles to
check out and you
or your wife or your girlfriend can look
like sweet little elisa after this
holiday season ted cruz
sticking by the fight i there have been
a lot of
it's been a lot of disinformation and
misinformation about this 2020 election
2020 election was almost a month ago
today
then for some reason it took them a long
time to count those votes
on election night it looked like trump
won pretty clearly then more votes came
in and then it looked like joe biden won
there have been
some irregularities there has been some
illegalities
in in some of these voting places and
the trump team is
promising that they're going to prove
that this was rigged and trump won
some some of trump's lawyers saying
trump won in a landslide
where does it stand now a lot of the
legal challenges have been
dismissed out of court there have been
challenges in the legislatures of these
states saying look there's evidence of
this fraud you can't ignore this you
should decertify the vote
are they going to decertify the vote it
seems unlikely just historically
speaking it seems very unlikely
so should we just give it up should we
just concede today i don't think so
i don't think that we should delude
ourselves and say there is a 100 chance
trump is gonna be declared the winner i
don't think that's true
i don't think that we should on the
other hand concede
and say no reason let's stop all these
legal challenges
before the electors vote on the 14th
let's just let's just give it up
don't think it would be good for the
country to give it i don't think that's
true either
i think there is a legal process we
should
fight through that legal process tooth
and nail
until the very end and it would appear
my friend and podcast co-host ted cruz
agrees with that as well
senator cruz just released this letter
yesterday
the statement is today an emergency
appeal was filed in the u.s supreme
court
challenging the election results in
pennsylvania this appeal raises serious
legal issues
and i believe the court should hear the
case on an expedited basis
what's the legal issue there's one in
particular it's not the dominion stuff
or the questions about the way even
certain votes were counted
you know there are some of those are
more serious challenges than others
but this is specific the pennsylvania
constitution requires
in-person voting except in narrow and
defined circumstances
late last year the pennsylvania
legislature passed a law
that purported to allow universal
mail-in voting notwithstanding the
pennsylvania constitution's
express prohibition of that this appeal
argues that pennsylvania
cannot change the rules in the middle of
the game if pennsylvania
wants to change how voting occurs the
state must follow the law
to do so this illegality was then
compounded by a partisan democrat
supreme court in pennsylvania which has
issued multiple decisions that reflect
their political and
ideological biases alito thomas gorsuch
wrote correctly
concerning the pennsylvania court uh
this previous decision to count ballots
received after election day
that quote there is a strong likelihood
that the state supreme court decision
violates the federal
constitution this is a very serious
legal challenge to the results
in pennsylvania the supreme court
absolutely should hear that out there
is absolutely no reason to concede the
presidential election
before that is heard now you might say
even if trump wins pennsylvania it's not
enough to push him over the top
okay fair enough fair enough the trump
campaign is pursuing other challenges in
other states
but but i don't even care i i don't care
if joe biden has every single electoral
vote in the country except for
pennsylvania
i want the supreme court to hear that
case because
the pennsylvania election officials
violated the law
very very clearly maybe in multiple
cases but certainly in that case
because of in-person voting absolutely
it should be heard out
conservatives need to grow a spine i'm
glad that ted cruz has one
and i hope that the court takes that up
we are we there are a lot of people
especially in the legacy media a lot of
people
are going squishy that's why we need to
replace the legacy media if you are not
a daily wire member now is the time to
join because we've got some
excellent stuff right around the corner
starting this friday december 4th
just a couple days from now the michael
knowles show is going five days a week
with more content for our members to
enjoy we are we're also going to radio
by the way in january that should be fun
too we're launching our first ever
feature film
under daily wire's upcoming
entertainment channel we are building a
new investigative journalism team
to replace the establishment media
cartel so
go outside the narrative come on over to
dailywire.com subscribe
we are loud we are opinionated we are
having a very good time
also if you haven't ordered them yet
check out our daily wire christmas
ornaments
you can get a little ornament of me
smoking a candy cane stogie on your
christmas tree
made out of metal they're really nice
designed actually by
a long time daily wire listener and
friend of ours it's all the hosts plus
the god king jeremy boring
as santa's adorable little elves uh
check it out they're gonna be a lot of
fun text christmas to
h3400 to get your tree decorated today
have us on your christmas tree that is
texting christmas
to eight three four zero zero they're
going very fast this is a limited
quantity so get
yours now and by the way be sure to
stick around later today we've got
programming going on all day of course
ben is going to be touching on the ellen
page slash elliott page
situation and you'll you'll remember
that ben famously when he
when he coined his phrase facts don't
care about your feelings it was because
he was challenging gender ideology
to a very unladylike individual
transgender individual on television who
then grabbed ben by the neck and said
uh if you don't cut that out talking
about genetics i'm going to send you
home in an ambulance
uh so i'm sure ben will have an
interesting perspective on that you can
check that out we'll be right back with
a lot more
so the pennsylvania legal challenge
totally legit there is no question there
whether or not
the trump campaign has the goods you
know it's it's
no one could argue that pennsylvania did
not violate
the pennsylvania constitution other
places
it's less clear there have been hearings
in arizona there have been hearings
all over the country there was a hearing
in michigan
at which this issue of dominion and the
software in the voting machines has come
up
there have been some fanciful theories
about what happened in the voting
machines i don't trust electronic voting
generally but we haven't gotten
specifics yet we haven't seen
the trump legal team prove that there
was
not not just that there could have been
fraud but that there was fraud
now we have in michigan the trump team
brought out a contractor for
dominion for the software that was used
in the voting machines
who insists that there was fraud
my name is melissa carone i am a
resident of wayne county
i have a background in i.t and cyber
security
i was contracted by pds staffing to work
with dominion voting systems assisting
with i.t at the tcf center
what i witnessed at the tcf center was
complete fraud
the whole 27 hours i was there there was
batches of ballots being ran through the
tabulating machines
numerous times being counted eight to
ten times
also the uh adjudication process
i witnessed numerous people walking up
claiming they were both democrats saying
they were going they were sitting
together judging ballots all night
together
all day together i witnessed it all i
was on the main stage with all of the
city officials
daniel baxter was in on the whole thing
and i am under the impression 100
that um at least 90 of those workers
were
all in on this there was not a single
ballot the whole night
the whole 27 hours i was there that i
saw that was for
donald trump not one not a single
bailout
that is that is scary there was
something going on
at that um department of elections
all right so the first allegation she's
making is
uh pretty serious and it's pretty
specific that they were just running
ballots through the machine multiple
times so that one person's vote a
democratic vote would be counted
multiple times which of course is
disenfranchising republicans it's
disenfranchising
everybody actually because you know the
every illegal vote takes away a vote
from from an eligible voter
okay so that's a specific one can they
prove it you know they've got this
woman's eyewitness testimony that
is not uh it's probably not sufficient
to overthrow an
election but you know it's pretty
significant it's pretty specific
then there's another charge which is
that something was going on
and no votes came in for trump and all
the votes were for biden
this i have no reason not to believe
it's true
this sort of thing does go on we don't
know if it went on
well we don't know if it went on at all
and if it did we don't know that it
would have gone on
to the degree that it could sway
thousands or tens of thousands
of votes or presidential election
because it happened in multiple states
but i'm not saying it didn't happen i'm
not saying it did happen
the only issue for the trump legal team
though is that
this charge the second charge more or
less amounts to something's going on
i'm telling you something's up
something's fishy yeah i know
you don't say obviously something's
fishy obviously there were tons of
irregularities
i don't mean to be angry with this woman
she's it's good that she's coming
forward and testifying
that argument is not going to be
sufficient i wish it were sufficient but
it won't be no court is going to hear
that argument frankly i don't think any
legislature is going to hear that
argument and say okay now we're going to
decertify a vote
now we're going to overturn an election
that is not going to work and that's
unfortunate i wish it did but
you know there is fraud that goes on in
every election unless you can
really drill down and prove that it was
widespread you can show where it
happened
then probably it's not gonna hold up in
court
another guy over here in michigan
another guy who's a poll watcher
gets to another aspect of these
irregularities that seem to have taken
place in a lot of places namely
that republicans were not admitted to
watch the poll count take a listen
i am an unaffiliated michigan voter who
was trained by the gop
to be a poll challenger on wednesday
november 4th beginning in the late
morning until around 8 pm
because i was told that they needed help
they didn't have they were understaffed
i witnessed the room erupt in thunderous
applause and derogatory cheering as
republican poll workers
were picked off one by one and ejected
from the room repeatedly
by police escort throughout the day by
the end of the day they had picked off
so many
gop poll workers that there were
probably only a few dozen left to
monitor all the processing stations in
the room
which i'm told was between 130 and 160.
so this is very specific right he's
saying yeah these republicans were
kicked out
a very small number were allowed to
remain so whenever you see the
politifact fact check there was a
republican poll watcher somewhere
okay where were all the rest of them and
by the way if that poll watch read to
stand
even six feet away but certainly 25 feet
away as we've heard in some cases
then the poll watcher is not going to do
very much i couldn't see it what's on a
ballot six feet away i could barely see
what's on a ballot six inches away
so that challenge very specific means
that votes were counted illegally we
know that this happened
we know it happened in georgia we know
for instance in georgia
we were told they had to shut down the
vote counting in certain places at 10 30
at night
and then the poll watchers went home and
then secretly vote counting went on
until 1 30 in the morning we know that
they made up a story about how a pipe
burst and that is why
the the the poll watchers had to go home
and we had to stop counting the vote
bs not not true no evidence that that's
true a lot of evidence
to the contrary so those are that's
where the challenges are
but here's the problem well i think
most of those kinds of testimonies are
legitimate
and they point to something that is
legitimate but
is it going to move the needle bill barr
the attorney general
says quote to date we have not seen
fraud on a scale
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election there has been
one assertion
that that would be systemic fraud and
that would be the claim
that machines were programmed
essentially to skew the election results
the dhs and doj have looked into that
and so far
we haven't seen anything to substantiate
that
i have no doubt that
these machines could have been open to
that hacking
i have no doubt that the democrats would
cheat
to do it and and have cheated
in certain places
not through the voting machines but
through other means but the problem for
the trump legal team is time dwindles
we're less than two weeks out
what are we 12 days out from the
electoral college vote
is you've got to prove that it
did happen i don't blame bill barr for
saying he hasn't found evidence of fraud
i'm sure he's looking for evidence of
fraud
i think he's a straight shooter i only
met the guy once but he seems like a
straight shooter to me
and his career i think backs that up
and they haven't shown it
i'm waiting sidney powell hasn't shown
it maybe she's showing it in court i
hope so i'm just saying the time
the time is running out i by the way i
don't think that that is
the fact that we haven't seen this hard
evidence
to a degree that would sway a judge to
overturn an election
i don't think that's a reason for us to
suddenly trust the election officials
or even to trust the election result
we'll have to address the election
result
depending on how the electoral college
votes because that's actually the way
that
our constitution sets up the election of
presidents but in terms of the people
voting at the polling stations yeah i
don't i think we should be skeptical of
that sort of thing
and i don't think that's conspiratorial
i don't think that's
kooky or are you wearing a tinfoil hat
of course we should be skeptical
and by the way the left gets to be
skeptical how come the left gets to be
skeptical
with with far less evidence for far less
grounds
for their skepticism of the government
than we are you saw this just
a couple nights ago on msnbc joy reid
one of my favorite people on msnbc
my doppelganger is my first favorite but
joy reid is my second because she is
really kooky
uh joy reid comes out and
is just talking to a guest about how
they're a little distrustful
of the kovid vaccine here's why you were
part of the
the moderna trial it looks like moderna
might be the one that has the highest
success rate so far
but number one i worry that it will that
just hearing that a vaccine
is coming will make people even more
lack they'll say you know what i'm gonna
do what i want because a vaccine is
coming that's one piece
and then the other piece is when it
comes particularly in our community
black people
they might be like i don't trust science
the science i mean we
you know tuskegee experiments etc
there's just not a lot of trust and it
was developed during the trump era i'm
worried about both are you worried about
those two things
yes i i'm very concerned about that i've
been talking about this in community and
i've been very
clear to say too often science has been
a tool of white supremacy
and what do i mean by that too often we
can look at a sordid historical legacy
of medical experimentation
medical exploitation that blacks and
browns has suffered whether it's
tuskegee whether it's henrietta lacks
whether it's mississippi appendectomies
or enslaved black women being forced to
undergo gynecological surgeries
i can't believe i'm saying this about a
joy read
program on msnbc
i think they're basically right
not they're not right in the specifics i
mean they think that trump is
i don't know gonna give everyone a
poison vaccine that's crazy
uh they think that white supremacy is
this major major problem in america
that's obviously crazy but the point
that they're making
that we should be skeptical of the
government and that science
is often used as a tool
for nefarious political ends
that is completely right and actually
when they're they use the phrase white
supremacy
white supremacy on the left just means
bad you know it's just a bi word for bad
or evil
and that's true that's true
science is a quasi-religious term that
is now invoked
by the left science what it really means
comes from the latin verb shire
it means knowledge to know and then
throughout
most of the history of the west it
encompassed all of knowledge and how we
acquire knowledge
then for the past 300 years or so it's
taken on this more narrow
sense of material inquiry so i can't i
can't pursue the science of
theology for instance that's considered
not a real science
but i can pursue the science of what
this leftist year's tumblr is made of
obviously it's made of just the highest
grade materials on the planet
and now in in the last few decades
maybe the last century even really since
the left
developed their theories of the science
of history and the science of politics
goes back to marx goes back to hegel
science has taken on this highly
politicized
definition whereby if you know the
science of history
you know the right side of history you
know the arc of history bends for
justice you know where we're going you
know what progress means you know
that utopia we're going to land at and
therefore there should be no public
debate therefore we should just follow
science
and once we know that you know andrew
cuomo in
new york the worst governor when it
comes to the coronavirus
epidemic his policies directly led to
the deaths of thousands of new yorkers
violated his own policies new york has
been affected worse than just about any
other state
but he says believe science and the left
they agree with they say yes believe
science
they ne they don't ever worry about the
double standard
what's science what does he mean by
science when we say believe dr fauci dr
fatty's a politician
he's a politician who's also a social
scientist of epidemiology which is a
social science right
it's a science that is as much about
people and the way that people behave
and interact
as it is about viruses is public health
public health means political health
public and political or synonymous
and politics will use the facade the
guise of science
to to their nefarious ends joy reid and
her guest
whoever that was totally right about
that
i just wish that conservatives were
permitted to make that point as well
because no one's going to call joy read
a science denier they're they are
explicitly saying
science is a tool of politics and we
shouldn't believe it they're
they are denying science right and no
one's going to call them that
i i just wish we could all be held to
the same standard there before we go i
have to get
to one very very sad aspect of the
collapse of our standards this is this
is the saddest
article i've read in many weeks if not
months
fraud i believe this is from new york
magazine
is a letter to the advice columnist
can i still charge my boyfriend rent
once we're married
dear charlotte my fiance and i live
together i own the house it's paid off
and he pays me 500
a month a pretty good deal very good can
i move in
the bills for the house are very low and
they come out to about 300
a month so essentially he's paying 200
in rent because i guess she's
paying the bills too he thinks that once
we get married he shouldn't have to pay
rent anymore and that we should split
the bills
evenly he's also stressed because he has
accrued some debt about 15 grand since
we've been together
wow since we've been together which is
partly why he thinks he should pay less
this frustrates me because i worked so
hard to pay off my house early and i
feel like he's taking advantage of that
he has made less money than me the
entire seven years we've been together
and it's been a constant issue in our
relationship i think that the man should
contribute a bit more than the woman
yeah you think i'd love to split
everything and to own a house together
but he's nowhere near being able to do
that
what's the fair option once you're
married
before we get to what happens once
you're married
i don't know if she watches the show i
hope she does before we get to
your marriage run run i know that you
own that house there should be a
u-shaped hole in the wall because you're
running so fast you don't even go to the
door
run this guy is a loser
this guy is worse than a loser
he has no standards at all he probably
talks to women like steve schmidt does
he's not a man he's not behaving like a
man
should you should you still be able to
charge your fiance
rent should you charge your husband rent
no because when you're married
you're gonna be one flesh are going to
be one
unit there is no his money and there is
no your money
i know that some people keep finances
separate they sort of pretend that
that's not real that's fake that's
imaginary when you're married it's all
the same stuff
and so you're taking on all of this
guy's failures and all of this guy's
vices and all of this guy's
childish behavior you won't be marrying
a husband you're going to be marrying a
child
who runs up all this debt while you're
paying off your debt
who doesn't understand that he's
supposed to be the head of his household
he shouldn't be paying rent to you he
should be paying
the rent he should be paying the
mortgage it should be his house he
should have a house
he shouldn't not have a house and you
should have a house you shouldn't be
working hard and he's not working
you wouldn't be marrying a man now in
the modern culture look we people once
understood this not that long ago
in the modern culture though even many
conservatives would say oh well you know
look he'll just
let's throw up your look you're all
people it's not that he's a man you're a
woman he's a husband you're a wife it's
look you're all people
you should split everything evenly you
should all do the exact same amount of
housework
you should pay the bills and equal
shares you should both go to work in
exactly the same way at exactly the same
type of company
no no that's not
it men and women are different i know
that ellen page would
or elliot elliott page now would dispute
that
but they're different doesn't mean he's
got to like
chain you to the kitchen and have you
cooking all day and it doesn't mean that
he's got to be working 16 hours
you know at the office uh you know in
the in the kind of
furthest caricatures of what it is to be
a husband and a wife
but husbands and wives are different and
if you're gonna you're not even gonna be
marrying a wife at least
wives provide quite a lot this guy's not
doing that at all
you'd be marrying a child and someone
who has no sense of standards at all
when you're a child sometimes you don't
have standards if you're not raised
right because
you have to be educated into them you
have to learn how to behave you have to
learn what those standards are
now we've got a whole nation of these
children they don't know if they're men
they don't know if they're women they
don't know what's up what's down
that's no way to go on if we want to fix
that we can't just keep throwing our
hands up in the air we have to offer
a political vision i'm michael knowles
it's the michael knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
assistant director pavel wodowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva and
production assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. you know the matt wall show it's
not just another show about
about politics i think there are enough
of those already out there we talk about
culture
because culture drives politics and it
drives everything else
so my main focuses are life
family faith those are fundamental and
that's what this show is about i hope
you'll
give it a listen